un campement gallo-romain reconstitué
sur le site de l'abbaye de Marmoutier
grâce à 140 figurants présents pour des
démonstrations et des ateliers ce
week-end on a remonté le temps à partir
du 1er siècle avant Jésus-Christ
quantours s'appelait kaisarodounum de
quoi ravir à les passionnés de l'époque
gallo-romaine reportage de Florent
Clavel
lui c'est Louis minus 8 ans apprend-il
légionnaire comme tous les Romains
débarqués à Tours en ce premier siècle
avant Jésus-Christ il est d'abord venu
en paix avant de sortir son épée
[Musique]
de l'équipement un peu tout une passion
encouragée par ses parents il aime ça il
aime faire vivre les événements il aime
participer et on encourage tout ça parce
que bah au moins il est loin de ses
écrans et on passe du temps ensemble
l'époque gallo-romaine une passion
française en ce dernier week-end d'août
la foule est venue nombreuse à Kaiser
Redonum du nom que portait la ville du
Haut Empire qui a précédé tours et
aujourd'hui un village reconstitué sur
le site de l'ancienne abbaye de
Marmoutier avec ses légionnaires
capables de faire du feu ou de frapper
la monnaie
nous avons le premier empereur romain de
son nom avant d'être empereur Octave qui
est devenu Auguste et de l'autre côté si
le général Agrippa lorsque je vais payer
les légionnaires grâce au marquage ça
permet à faire deux choses la propagande
et aussi informer tout l'empire du
résultat qui a eu lors de cette guerre
civile
money mais aussi construction médecine
tactique d'infanterie durant l'Antiquité
la civilisation romaine était l'une des
plus avancées et c'est ce qui fascine
encore aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle les
reconstituteurs 140 présents à ks-0
donum féru d'histoire et de découverte
moi il y a plus de 30 ans que je fais de
l'art constitution romaine on en apprend
encore tous les jours parce qu'en fait
il faut réactualiser ce que l'on a pris
il y a 30 ans et il y a des spécialistes
et des fouilles archéologiques et des
spécialistes qui va se remettre en
question ils font des tests si il y a de
l'archéologie expérimentale aussi après
avoir dominé le bassin méditerranéen une
partie de l'Europe l'Empire romain
prendra fin au cinquième siècle mais on
dit qu'il renaît une fois par an à Tours